hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
it is the first of July and you're
watching games what news first up today
if you haven't been able to get your
hands on the fallout 4 pip-boy addition
you may want to get in touch with Reddit
user the MCV who's created his very own
3d printed pip-boy this inventive
fallout fan used a 3d printed cast and a
raspberry pi computer to create a
functional replica pip-boy the computer
inside runs a recreated pip-boy user
interface developed by another user and
it pulls your location information if
you've loaded the Google Maps API on to
it the replica is controlled by keyboard
but it won't be going on sale instead
the MTV is getting serious brownie
points by giving it to a friend as a
Christmas gift next up the ps4 has
received a version 2.55 system software
update and like most stories on
incremental software updates this is
going to be a short one the reason for
that is while you guys love your patch
news the one line in the update notes
simply says system software stability
during use of some features has been
improved this is just routine for Sony
but unfortunately this news is sometimes
very upsetting to gamers / pine for
substantial feature add-ons at every
corner the patch is mandatory so you'll
get it either way and we can all move on
with our lives allegedly batman arkham
knight publisher warner brothers knew
that there were several significant
issues with the pc version for months
anonymous sources from Warner Brothers
to hold kotaku quote i will say that
it's pretty rich for Warner Brothers to
act like they have no idea the game was
in such a horrible state it's been like
this for months and all the problems we
see now with the exact same unchanged
almost a year ago the sources have also
claimed that the publisher chose to ship
the game believing that it was good
enough another source confirmed that
Rocksteady did not work on the pc
version at all and that its development
was entirely
outsourced to iron galaxy studios
despite the impression you might get
from iron galaxy only being credited for
additional engineering and pc support it
was added that Rocksteady found it
challenging to develop for the new
consoles and that their QA team was
quote not nearly as easy to work with as
they expected allegedly of the
approximately 100 person QA team only
ten percent were focused on the pc
version another of kotaku sources said
that Warner's internal QA team only
focused on bug checking at 720p and of
those who did find bugs it was said that
quote dads would fix what they could but
they were juggling with actually
finishing the games so they were
insanely slow finally Rocksteady also
avoided sending the game to traditional
PC stress testing firms the fear of the
game's plot being spoiled we should note
the game spot has not been able to
personally verify these sources or
details let me know down in the comments
what you think of this Batman PC
disaster you can head to gain spot where
we've got stories on July PS Plus games
and the Microsoft saying that the Xbox
one needs to do better in Europe that is
everything I've got for you today be
sure to leave me your thoughts in that
comment box and I'll catch you again
tomorrow